[Music]
at its start benjamin netanyahu's
election campaign was all about
bringing israel back to life through
covid19 vaccines
by the time it finished the message had
boiled down to one phrase
two more seats repeatedly telling his
supporters he was within touching
distance
of the 61 needed for a majority
coalition
it's the largest gap between two leading
parties in israel in the last dozen
years
there is a large majority within the
people of israel and with this majority
in the knesset who believe in our
principles
it's possible and needed to set up a
stable government in israel a fair
government
i reach out to all members of the
knesset who believe in these principles
i won't rule out anyone i expect them to
do the same
naftali bennett was styling himself as a
netanyahu alternative
the question now is whether his yamina
party's seven or eight seats will be
enough to get netanyahu
over the finish line there's no reason
why we should go to a fifth election
and they must come to netanyahu and say
we want to be part of the government we
accept the results of this round
uh inform a right of center government
that could aggressively pursue the
opportunities we have ahead of us
earlier election day itself had been hot
and hazy
a running tally of ballots cast
suggesting the lowest turnout in years
netanyahu crisscrossed the country to
squeeze out every last vote
warning his core voters that turnout was
particularly bad
in his liquid strongholds
[Applause]
but it was in palestinian israeli areas
where the falloff seemed most severe
the mainly arab joint list with 15 seats
in the previous parliament
is projected now to have as few as eight
after splitting in two
the smaller group failing to get into
the parliament at all
meanwhile the far-right religious
zionist alliance promoted by netanyahu
and featuring an advocate of removing
disloyal arabs from the country
outperformed expectations
opposition leader yay lapid says relying
on their seats would create a homophobic
racist illiberal government and one that
would shield netanyahu from his
corruption trial
i think we can have a good reason to be
proud of the way we handled ourselves
and even a bigger reason for the result
we brought
at the moment netanyahu doesn't have 61
seat but the change block does
the exit polls have already changed
several times since their first release
coronavirus voting and counting
protocols could delay the official count
until friday benjamin netanyahu has
claimed victory before only to have it
dashed away
this time he does have some options
perhaps a campaign to try to peel away
defectors
from other right-wing parties israelis
in four elections now
have delivered almost identical verdicts
and again it's over to the political
deal makers to try to
find a way out of the gridlock harry
fossett al jazeera
west jerusalem